what our Tundras Tundras are among the
earth's coldest and harshest biomes
these ecosystems are treeless regions
with extreme cold and low rainfall there
are two different types of Tundras
alpine and arctic alpine tundra occur on
mountains where trees cannot grow in the
high altitudes there the growing season
is about 180 days mountain goats sheep
marmots and birds feed on low-lying
plants and insects Arctic tundra extends
from the edge of the Arctic Ocean down
to the coniferous forests of the taiga
permafrost prevents trees from taking
root
but shrubs and other vegetation grow
during the short summers which range
from fifty to sixty days a variety of
wildlife including arctic foxes polar
bears and caribou live in the Arctic
tundra global warming is changing the
Arctic tundra and the changing Tundra is
contributing to global warming the
Arctic permafrost is deteriorating which
alters not only the landscape but also
the plants and animals that can live
there
in addition permafrost contains about
14% of the Earth's carbon so as it melts
that carbon is released into the
atmosphere contributing to global
warming
[Music]